hey Jenny some days the Democrats
weren't unanimous in impeaching Donald
Trump three voted against it and one
Jeff van drew of New Jersey is now going
to join the Republican Party the
president expressed his defiance after
meeting van drew at the White House it
doesn't feel like impeachment and you
know what it's a phony deal and they
cheapen the word in Pietra it's an ugly
word but they cheapen the word
impeachment that should never again
happen to another president we think
that what they did is wrong we think
that what they did is unconstitutional
earlier the Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell attacked Wednesday's vote in
the House of Representatives to impeach
the president as the fulfillment of a
long-held Democratic Party plan to
overturn the results of the 2016
election the houses vote yesterday was
not some neutral judgment the Democrats
came to with great reluctance
it was the predetermined end of a
partisan crusade that began before
President Trump was even nominated let
alone sworn in McConnell has already
said that he will take his cues from the
White House as he oversees a Senate
trial for the president the Democrats
aren't happy
leader McConnell claimed the impeachment
was motivated by partisan rage this from
the man who said proudly I am NOT
impartial I have no intention to be
impartial at all in the trial of
President Trump what hypocrisy
immediately after Wednesday's vote Nancy
Pelosi refused to commit to sending the
articles of impeachment to the Senate
for consideration some Democrats have
argued no trial should take place unless
there are guarantees of fairness
however on Thursday police he seemed to
be speaking in terms of when a trial
would occur and not if the trial would
take place the next thing for us will be
when we see the process that is set
forth in the Senate then we'll know the
number of managers that we may have to
go forward
but we'd like to see a fair process but
we'll see what they have and we'll be
ready for whatever it is the Democrats
want to be able to call witnesses as
they make their case in the Senate
McConnell has said he wants as swift a
proceeding as possible the House
Democrats making their case and the
White House making its defense
only then will witnesses be considered
Congress begins its Christmas recess
this week the entire month of January
has been set aside in the Senate for
impeachment proceedings but as of now
it's unclear when the trial will occur
Sheraton C al Jazeera Washington